这个部分的话我们今天大家今天大家会持续45分钟左右吧啊过程中大家如果有什么问题随时在我们的直播间跟我们互动呃刚才我看有一个同学说好像刚进来就已经结束了其实没关系啊因为我们后面还有录播的放心我们一定会把卡比这些精华的东西我们持续的把它沉淀下来让更多的同学可以看到那我们先正式进我们今天的访谈环节那第一个点啊第一个点就是我们大家可能比较关心的
就是B站的一个技术选型的特点是什么然后是怎么样去沉淀下来的这个我觉得卡比可以给大家具体的讲一讲嗯ok对就是怎么说呢就是选型吧选型选型那第一个就是选可能有很多很多东西你要去选它那有一个很关键的一个事情就是选之前必须得有原则对那什么原则那我我可能说一下我自己认为
怎么说呢就是一站子一些原则了第一个原则我自己看法一定是向未来看就是面向未来对怎么说这件事情呢就是就比如说我们系统架构里面嗯很关注一件事情叫向前兼容嗯比如说我现在一个API设计的不合理如果说我一旦发布了那我唯一能后面做的就是永远向前兼容
其实这件事情是个很对研发很痛苦的一件事情那么一般性公司比如说到了到一直向前见证兼容到不行了然后来播痛的来割弯一下ok我来个v2甚至来个v3 v4 v5对一般是这样的一个模式但是我自己觉得b站的一个选情其实对他而言他有一点叫做不向前见证为什么不像那怎么做到不向前见证包括是使用类似model rappel这样的一些
一些模式一些选情其实就是为了出发这件事就是能达成这个目的来做的嗯然后那就不向前兼容了以后那么我们要做到的是通过一些更丰富的一些技术战对去可以去去去migrate他的小塔甚至是直接一次性的去改写掉我们所有不兼容的带马让每个模块自己的负担就是意识再变的第一对这是第一个点
第二点的话其实就是用最先进的一些工具链这是我自己特别关注的一件事情就是一定要最新的工具链就像实际时代对我自己也打帝国每一个时代最重要的一个事情一定是工具就像我们最早的话包括应该B站应该是最早一波包括和气牛那边类似一样的早期的购物源的后端的使用者
你看现在我前两天还看到一个新闻说头条字节是好像是够已经成为了就是就是最大的一个一个语言嗯然后那么比如说B站早KT Kotlin在加瓦层面也是最早使用到的一个一个一个平台对然后Swift一旦5.0刚出了以后啊就是包括B站就是整个技术站其实显示传播所谓的去靠的这是我认为的选心的第二个点最新兴的一个旧站
那第三个点技术选情我自己认为的叫做说嗯感改东西就像就像14年的时候对我之前其实在一家创业公司我们很痛苦的一件事情叫做说没人会写播放器然后播放器只要出现问题就头痛但是B站那个时候有一个能力叫做说他自己写播放器在14年就自言了完整的播放器然后包括当后面也出出了很多大成对
那么这就是另外最后我想说的一个选择特点就是赶自己录东西只要是自己需要的对 它就赶你录然后自己是需要的并且没问题的它就赶用就像比如说我们自己使用了Promming的一些内核等等的这样的一些比较难的一些技术战对然后那么特点大概是这些那最后是怎么沉淀的呢对 你选了这种东西肯定会有
肯定会有买不买账啊类似这样的一些点那怎么去买不买账呢就是我自己早期是那种强推型的我现在其实变了我现在变成不强推型了就是你好的东西自然会使用它自然就成全下来了没人用的东西那就是你选错了你承认错误对该淘汰该淘汰该怎么样怎么样就不要去强迫就就就完事了大概这样其实我我整体听下来我感觉
嗯卡比这边就比如说B站这边相对来说还是相对比较偏极客的这感觉对吧就是敢于去做一些比较冒险的事情包括做一些新鲜的尝试对这可能是偏精精导致的吧就像就早期的包括我那就是那一波人都是感觉比较肥的那种对我明白就我觉得这是很好的因为技术人的话如果
大家都很保守的话比如说我们就秉承不做不做这种想法去做事情的话那我觉得一个公司的技术是很难去有一个大的成长的所以所以我觉得我觉得还蛮有意思的那那包括比如说像包括这去过程有个成长就比如说你以前可能说感觉说不像以前那会去强推还是可能这种改变其实怎么样去导致的呢其实我也很想了解就是其实啊
就是說的功力一點就是你級別高了你再去搶腿這件事情就味道就變了你知道嗎你級別高了就變成命令式的了然後過程中你發現你不能在類似這樣的方式去命令別人去做一些
选型或者说是使用推进你的这个基础站的一种方式了那你换一个角度你开始不去那么强硬的铺去的时候你会发现其实有一些东西你的确就是没做好那就是大概是类似这样的一个过程中的一个转变哎我是不可以理解这也相当于是比如说你在这个架构式路上可能也走向成熟的一个一个变化的过程算是吧可以可以挺好
行那我们继续讨论下一个问题啊就因为我们今天在讲这个架构这个部分嘛那其实肯定大家都很关心就比如说刚才呃我觉得卡比他在第一个分享里面其实也分享了很多他呃在架构上面的一些思考那因为大家可能我们竟然会讲就是呃这个成长的路线嘛比如说对于移动端开发者我们竟然讲从呃初级到中级到高级到资深
那再往后面走的话可能会走技术专家或者说走架构师的路线那我们很多同学可能会选择走这个架构师的路线那我可能大家就想问一下就如果从一个移动架构师需要具备哪些能力呢就是在他比从你的角度来看嗯对这个话题特别大对就是包括每一个人的一个直接发展我只能用我自己来举例子对肯定不能不能说成为一个架构师什么的你可能说我自己的话
第一我个人认为叫做说要坚持不懈的写达嘛对就是既然你没有走manager这条线啊那你就一定要自己写达嘛但是你会碰到一个问题就是没办法让你写这个事情很尴尬那没没没办法让你写你怎么办呢其实我是这么来解决的叫做说比如说你设计了一个套价给我方案你比如说你推进是让某一些同学去推进的
这个时候你偷偷的你自己你也写一遍就是你看这个需求你对着一些那个就是文档你也把这个需求写一遍你写完了以后你在看那个同学写的你去看他写的跟你是不是match或者说是不是你的想法对这个时候你就会有大量的办法去写就是第一个点叫做说一直要去写然后
第二个点的话就是可能我自己的话叫做说嗯就是我一开始介绍我自己说是个权战其实其实这个就是权战就是什么都不行其实差不多就是什么都看对什么都看就是上下的技术什么都看服务技术也看然后跨单技术也看外面技术也看什么都看什么都看的时候就融会贯通出来了就像比如说facebook那个就是facebook的react
其实你会发现react的这个思想它就是全大前端这样通用的一个思想比如说single source就是react里面的一个原则single source它就是那个不管是前端后端统一统一的一个一个设计思想对然后这是第二个点就是你去不停的接触你的商家有还有兄弟的一个东西
第三个是第三个我自己的观点其实跟我前面说的选情比较像就是选事情太多了或者说方案太多了你接收到的信息也太多了就是太多太多了那你必须得有一个自己的一个方法论文原则这个这个听起来很很很阿里味啊对但是这个真的是要必须要有你自己的原则而你的决策就是这个原则就是听多数人的话自己做这个
然后还有就是一定要多怎么说呢多接受input必须要多接受input而最好的接受input的这个点怎么接受就是去看文章对那我可能更推荐包括比如说老四季周报的这些我们国内的一些高质量的文章对也有一些包括外网Million的一些文章包括一些对一定要去做input大概
我自己的观点可能就这几个吧嗯对我理解就是呃其实所谓呃可能从价格视角来说因为呃当然我我现在可能没有太多资格讲这个事情啊因为我现在其实已经走tl路线哈哈哈就你说那个没有代码可写的问题就对我来说可能都不是没代码可写就是没有时间写就想起也没有时间写对但但以前其实我走的也是我我觉得吧我自我感觉我走的可能也是价格式的那个路线
所以有一点我觉得卡宾讲那一点我其实蛮赞同的就可能要接受各种Import因为其实架构师可能确实是他需要在很多不同的方案中做选刑嘛那其实你肯定是要有足够多的输入你要去了解足够多的方案你才能知道哪些方案是比如说他们居然是有共性的或者说哪些方案在某些点有什么优势有什么劣势你可能正要了解清楚了之后你可能才会根据你当前的一个业务情况去做一个具体的选刑
我是这么理解的就我在做架构师的时候因为大概做了两年左右的架构师吧就没有做太多的管理的时候对然后就简单为主吧其实我觉得我觉得很多东西复杂是复杂在自己给一层一层跌出来了就是架构或者说一个东西的本质其实很简单我们只要能做到不停的refact或者说不停的去刚才像我那视频一样的去形成迭代
明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,明白,
那我还是可能以我自己例子就是说我刚来公司我也是个就是写业务代码的一个一个这样的一个角色嘛对就是嗯做什么准备的话就是我刚才说的其实他并不是到了架构时才做的嗯我不知道你能不能理解到这个就是这个我们的理解不停的对不停的写代码和不停的输入input看东西并不是说OK我今天
甚至了我態度變成叫採取大家不是OK我就要開始今天開始我就不起來了我天天幹這件事不是的就是我可能來公司的第一天我每天幹的就是這件事要可能說我以前有代碼線對那我我我我我我我以前有生產代碼線我現在可能變成我沒生產代碼線但是我有經常代碼線對我以前可能是不是我現在以前接受的是那個比如說安卓端的和iOS端兩端雙端的一個公共技術端
现在变成OK我要去看后段我要去看差不多对就是他他并不是一个突进的过程他就是时时刻刻他做的一件事情对嗯我如果给就是偏笑招或者出街的同学的建议的话其实大家我又不是一个类上一个角色对我
我建议其实就是写多了自己有感觉了就像一万小时原则一样对明白就还是说要多去尝试嘛就除了说把自己本职工作做好的情况下你能去多尝试一些不同的文化是不同的语言战还是说不同的那个技术的技术的或者说技术的项目吧我是这么理解的对吧就对你就不管是在哪个阶段可能你在初级中级高级都要尝试去做更多的事情
我是这么感觉ok好的那我还有这个直播界还有同学有个问题就是有的同学比如说一方面是有些同学可能他在目前的记录站比较单一嘛然后另外还有些同学就是对这个全站这个东西比较感兴趣就我们也不要也聊一下就比如说因为我看你的感觉就是可能你没有太给自己射线嘛就你自己就扩充了很多各种各样的一些记录站
全家是这样的 我就偏小一点嘛就是还是以前端技术战这个角度来看的话对 我说的建议就是超web就是超html.js.cds.s这套技术战对 因为比如说比较吹的多的就是现在天天说web3 其实web2.0那我们当初web2.0的整个结构其实就是在浏览器上
就整个互联网的生态包括B站早期也就是在浏览期结构的这个生态上诞生的这也就意味着Web技术站其实是相对持用人数最多然后发展的最全面的一个技术站那么其实比如我们可以看到13年13年Facebook就做了React这样的一个Web技术站那我们从结果来看我记得Sluity UI是18年还是19年去我容易忘记了对然后做的
其实我记得当初虽然我文档上看到过他说是inspired by rat后面被干掉了可能是评过自己的尊严对然后不管是flutter还是那个叫什么那个compose其实你可以从他的文档啊或者各种地方都可以看到他是深度被inspired by rat那么这也就是怎么说呢就是如果说你要我骗一个全占每一个思想来看就你一定要去理解的是
外部的這個技術然後推向比如說在 native 層面它是怎麼去其實 native 在我看看它就是一個 Chrome 的殼就是它就是個 Chrome 的級別的東西它是一個容器的東西你可以有非常多去借借比如說 Chrome 怎麼來做呢對 Webpeter 是怎麼來做的對那這是偏比層的那偏上層的就比如說業務結構怎麼來寫比如說當初的那個狀態管理比如說移動技術站天天在那喊 MVM這些東西
那是不是更先进的比如说react里面的hook对这样的一些pnfp形式的这些东西可能就是下一步未来对那么我的给到的一个建议是从前端的一些技术站看起来去如果你啥我都是安卓的一个技术站同学从那个角度去给你启发去往那个方向去靠对明白ok没问题好的那我们还是接着往下
继续走吧因为我们还有将近10个问题还要继续讨论那直播间问题我们一会确实来一会来回答OK 然后因为刚才那个卡比的直播里面有讲到这个mono ripple的一个实践嘛所以我很想了解一下因为其实b站可能也是我理解就在我了解中可能是国内应该也是比较就是比较重度的在用mono ripple的一个公司吧对然后比如说我就想知道比如说b站这个整个mono ripple的时间路径是什么样子的然后你是怎么去看待这样的一个选择的
嗯对嗯其实说实话就是每个就是天使地利人和嘛这个东西很重要就是你比如说你人和假设了就是你全都是过过来或者是facebook接受天天以前的工作环境就是model report的但是每天是地利你也搞不定对那么b站其实他有一个很重要的天使吧对就b站大概是18年的时候开始做的就是推的model report
對為什麼會去做這個事情那就是碰到的一個問題就是剛才我可能前面分享寫到的那個圖嘛就是我們百萬好幾別的代碼那個時候其實就已經百萬一八年應該就是百萬好幾別的這種代碼級別了我們碰到一個很具體的一個問題就很具體特別具體的一個問題叫做說我們發版的時候沒有凌晨四點前下班過對
就是一个特别特别具体的问题为什么呢因为大家都是以一种二净之交付然后大家因为特别赶工那二净之交付出来又我刚才说的那些可恶的模块化之间故意让模块之间拆除结有然后通过一些偏RPCIPC的这种通行方式去搞结果
结果这个包那个时候我们是这么讲我们一般10点就半就是晚上凌晨不是晚上10点11点的打出这个包都已经觉得这个这个这个是今天这个版本质量不错那运行起来就是奇迹了然后开始去调到底什么问题然后那时候我们一些同学其实很多时候很多理智是扛不住这种状态的就是其实就是因为这个原因我觉得必须要去做一些改变那么这个其实就是推进摩托的起因
那么很多公司其实在这个阶段其实很多公司都碰到过这个阶段但是他们没有选择model record的原因是他们通过一些上前兼容更偏管理化就是偏管理的手段去解决扛过了这个阶段对那么B站因为在那个阶段其实它的代码量百辆行还在一个可控制的一个级别上因为都是可能少数几个人写的
對那麼在這個階段下我們有能力去做了這樣的一個轉身假設比如說今天到了2021年可能真的就做不了這個事了對這是就是怎麼時間過來的吧對我認為然後呢這個時間過了其實也比較坎坷坎坷過程包括一些代碼全面洩漏啊導致分分合合包括其實我們的後段其實目前
从早期的ModelReport又拆成了PoloReport的一个结构当然也基本期合我们的微服武汉价等等这样的一些改变那么时间过程中看看可可了那怎么看待这条路的选择其实我自己目前下来其实是不后悔的并且其实是非常赞同这件事的为什么会赞同这件事情呢当然也有很多包括我们公司内部也
也很多抱怨吐槽说OK我编一个东西我要可能可能下来一个非常非常可怕级别的一个代码量器对然后我们还自定一个大量的一些工具链包括我们抛弃了大家熟悉的就是iOS技术上的那个插口的build对我们可能采用了类似BattleBattle的一些技术战对大家非常的抱怨但是我们得到了对我们得到了什么东西我举一个例子啊就我刚才说其实B站是一个偏平台化的一个
一个结构平台化的一个APP这样的一个平台化项目它并不是一个片垂类的那在这个基础上其实是我们包体自己的控制以及那个那个我们模块化的一些高度服就不是模块就是我们模块之间的一些基础件的高度服用其实在我看来都是model ripple的带来的一个红利对就像可以我们看到很多公司会采取片片
不管是阿恩还是什么一些动态化的一些技术会把大量的一些东西给那个后下化掉当然这个等会后面会去讲其实他也其实说实话是牺牲了一部分的用户体验但是我自己个人认为我们B站的话是在内容体验这个层面其实是对就是为了用户的体验去追求到极致的会使用就是这就是摩托车步大量的一个价值了对明白
所以所以我从我的理解来说也是根据当前当时的现状然后做的一个选择对吧它其实也是你讲到的那个价格式里面的一个选型的问题它就是一个选型的实践对不对对对对可以哎对这个东西就是我们目前来说在我们现在整个B站这边运用的情况是什么样子的是不是就已经全线都在用了
當然還有一些APP其實不是的就像我剛才截圖裡面我們還是會有一個中心化的一個一個Postrade這樣的一個倉庫它其實是服務於一些更小型的一些APP它並不想去繼承一個這麼大級別的一個codebase對其實是為這些APP服務的當然只能說的是我們的主項目
就是主項目的一些流程並且我們的基礎庫就是info的這個基礎站的推進都是基於這個model report的這個時間按作嗯 我明白所以其實可能就是做的一個選型當然他可能會帶來一些小的副作用但是能解決一些大的問題所以相當於也就是一個我們做的所謂的可能沒有完全的就沒有銀彈嘛沒有什麼都能解決的這種問題只能說是在現有條件下能解決大家的大問題
这样的一个选择好的明白明白OK那时间关系我们今天往下过因为我看今天我们已经到了9点我们原计划45分钟聊完可能不太现实我们继续往下聊吧嗯对然后我们再聊一下这个对因为我们今天所有的话题啊其实都是围绕着架构师这样的去去展开的因为大家都知道因为今天我们的主题是我在必然做架构嘛所以我们可能很多问题都是跟架构师相关的比如说如何去看待重构这个事情
然后他比在B站这边是怎么去实践的我们也很想了解一下这个我加速一点重构这个点的话我举个例子我举个例子其实我刚才其实聊过就是重构其实可以减化就是刚才就是我一开始发说就是PPT里面的第一个现象叫做说human human capability和那个complexity这个
一個關係結構那麼重構其實在我看來就是一個求導的過程比如說我把那個二次寒暑求導它就變成一次寒暑了就是現今寒暑了 對變成現今寒暑了以後那是不是就可以更和那條黃線人類的一個治理去match對 重構就這樣一個動作那麼我舉到一個具體的生活例子比如說我們城市的下水道管道 對
下水道管道那么我们会默认的说OK我们把城市的一些五五垃圾去往那个地方去通所以在重构这件事情来说比战可能比战第一是鼓励重构的那怎么是实践这个重构这个动作就偏向那个污水管道这样的一个节奏对我们需要在说难听点就是代码一直说史山嘛那就在史山形成之前我们觉得告诉大家有个东西叫马桶对
你不要去去去随地抛分你要这像当年欧洲中时期的时候就随便抛分就就非常可怕对我们要告诉他们有这个地方可以抛分那么有了这个地方抛分了以后他就可以解决什么问题他就是一个缓冲带他就缓冲带就可以让大家有有有精力时间因为大家工作压力都特别大需求时间要求都特别大那有这个缓冲带了以后他就可以在这个缓冲带里面
去批量的去进行一些改造重购然后重购在我看来除了技术之外它其实也是一种帮助产品发挥更大价值的一个契机比如说重购一些烂代码或者没有的代码过程中产品其实是在帮助你一起梳理这个过程梳理过程的时候它其实不太有思考它会有思考为什么没人用它为什么它会变成实产品其实
在这个过程中他会跟着技术一起去让你的这种产品去得到他这个级别的成功而不只是你技术上的一个成功对然后最后一个点我觉得怎么实践这件事情就特别重要了我觉得这个点一定要说的一个人说很多人喜欢怎么说呢他都说做项目就像比如打仗的人打仗那个人都说打仗的人难那守城的人不难吗就是你就比如说
把問題解決的那個人他其實是要得到獎勵的把問題解決的人一定要得到獎勵他不是說他就是這波東西的紅利被別人吃了以後他就沒有了不能這樣而得到獎勵的那個或者說叫做產出史山的那個人對他需要做到的一個能力叫做說快捲很快速的去弄要膽子要大而這個其實對人的要求特別特別高
高风险必须得给到高手艺不然就永远是史山这是我对重够的这么一个时间的看法对那个卡比讲到这个史山这个问题我就想起我之前我之前就是因为有段时间我自己在画漫画嘛我当时有一段时间还画了一个是一样的代码的系列的一个漫画的东西对然后对因为我当时记得我特别有一期就是
我当时画了一场就是他把那个屎吃进去嘛然后又拉出来一坨屎但是我就拉出来一坨更大的屎对所以刚才其实直播间有一个有一个朋友问到说怎么样去评论这个重构之后他的一个体量对我是这么实践的就是对这个问题特别特别好怎么去评论这个这个东西就是你在做这个重构之前你要先给他预期你不要预期说OK我这东西做得多好多牛逼你要给他一个明确的说我能包
保六個月我能保一年我能保兩年然後呢我剛才比如說要得到獎勵嗎怎麼看得到獎勵這件事情就我比如說從我的觀念看法這件事很簡單就比如說有位同學他述職說OK我做了一個某某的東西重構那我怎麼考核這件事情呢這個事情特別抽象怎麼考核這個事情那你就問他你重構完的東西在半年內有多少人改過他發生了多少變化
這些變化是你當初預期到的嗎或者說這是你預期中的嗎這就是一個非常好的檢驗一個重構的東西的標準因為重構肯定是沒有好壞的就是我把一些一些公共的業務邏輯放在一起就是所謂的很高內職也很高偶和但它也許就是一個非常好的重構其實這就是我可能的一個品牌標準
OK 也就是说因为其实我大概理解你说那个点就是看被多少人改过我理解就是如果是一个合理的架构的话理论上他应该会做到一个比较扩展器就至少不会动上他自己核心的那部分的代码我不知道我理解的是对的明白就大家改了更多的可能是会基于你当前的一些基础代码去做一些扩展可能那个是比较想要的一个结果对吧那在比如说我们在因为做成功的话肯定会有一些投入成本嘛
那比如说我们也会看这个吗比如说你这个价格能保两年但是你可能会投入两个月的时间去开发期这样来看的话他的ri也是还不错的很低的是这样的一个对对这个就是跟业务力道去对跟tl里去去去去battle的这样的一个过程对因为重过的话其实我们还会看很多比如说一方面业务这一块的因素可能还会再看稳定性方面的因素是吧这些东西也都会对
当然稳定性这方面如果稍微展开一点就是我特别推荐的就是就包括什么model level其实对稳定性特别重要因为它有feature flap它可以特别自由的在一个非常多立不的情况下可以做到每个立不的快速变更但是在我们传统那种中心化那个binary的结构下其实这件事是不可能做到的这也是我
之前说的就是mati report最难的一个事情或者说就是我最不喜欢的一个事情就是他不可迭代不可实施就是或者说他每一次持续迭代都是对整个项目的声明就是一个非常严重的一个break chain就像在B站的话比如说我基础库我们可以一个基础库的负责人改代吗他可以
就是一个commit的级别可以把所有的优点全部改掉但是原来的情况是很多这种说法这个我理解因为我们以前就是你说的multiple repo就你要改一个东西你会发现你要改好多好多其他的裤而且这些裤还不一定是你能维护的对是的有很多这样的问题啊这个协作成本是比较高的ok好的那我们再接着往下过下一个问题给我看
直播间应该没有别的问题那么接往下过我们聊了这么多干的东西我们还是聊一点稍微轻松一点的话题我觉得大家一聊到B站肯定会想到二次元对不对那我想知道一下比如有没有什么二次元的一些氛围然后有没有一些什么特殊的福利比如说有想去B站的同学可能会对这方面比较感兴趣B站的一些
就面向全部员工分两部分一部分面向全部员工一部分偏向程学员这一块话就全部员工的话就是一些包括家庭日然后比较生日六二六大家可以记住啊对一般人都会有活动六二六的一些私信然后每个节日活动或者说日常工作中会有些生日生日会对那一般生日会就是去蹭吃蹭喝去的那一般是这样子然后呢还有的话一个比较特点的就是
就是公司動物很多當然貓最多主要是貓動物很多還有很奇怪的動物比如說我一直擔心公司裡的一些蒼獸會不會被貓吃掉貓會不會被貓吃掉的然後貓基本上到處都是基本上每一層都有一些貓然後我們貓還有一個特點都有公牌我每隻貓都有公牌然後還有偏二次元文化這一塊的話
这个就刚才说到了第二部分和技术相关其实技术说错了那个就是猛妹子这一块就是和技术这边就是妹子比较少对事实但是如果大家比较扭逼可以去向外开口比如说对我们技术这边还有不少同学很很就社交很厉害对然后技术这边更多的会对因为男生多嘛就是二次元的话主要一些
對來這邊你會找到很多主機玩家我也是還有一些交流對這些興趣愛好是可以得到那個充分交流的然後編程序員這一塊的話我們會有Hexxon在1024的時候會去做一些解謎探秘的一些東西然後像去年應該獎勵是3080當然我肯定是沒有的
大概就是这样的一些福利吧我想问一下有没有女装大佬这边女装大佬都有有 真有 还不少但我们组或者说我们部门好像没有对可以 对 因为我看那个好像我为大家说一下因为我看那个卡比之前有颇了一些关于B站内部氛围的一些微信公众号的链接
然后后续的话我们会在总结里面去放出来就是那些具体的整个B站的一些二次元文化的氛围然后大家到时候也可以看一下我们的总结那我们具体就不展开了